okay so ryan reynolds is back in a brand
new movie where he plays a sassy guy
with razor sharp one-liners no it's not
deadpool no it's not the hitman's
bodyguard it's the adam project a timey
whimey wibbly wobbly film that sees the
titular character traveling back in time
to team up with his younger self the
wrexham football club co-owner has
reunited with free guy director sean
levy and i'm pleased to say that just
like that movie the adam project is
great now whilst free guy was a better
ready player one than ready player one
the adam project delivers a movie that
wears its 80s sci-fi influences right on
its sleeve it's a glorious amalgamation
of things like et back to the future the
last star fighter and flight of the
navigator throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the entire
thing but there will be heavy spoilers
ahead and i don't want your future self
to have to go back to you right now
watching this to tell you to stop what
you're doing it's on you if you go past
this point and with that out of the way
yeah thanks for clicking this i hope you
enjoy it now let's get into the adam
project okay so the movie opens in 2050
with adam taking a fighter jet in order
to travel back in time throughout the
film we learned that time travel was
accidentally invented by adam's father
lewis in 2018. he ended up dying and it
massively affected adam's childhood and
his adult life another adam initially
wants to rescue his wife laura the
entire point of the film eventually is
to stop time travel from being invented
as we discover that 2050 is basically
the terminator timeline times t1000 this
is because a character known as saurian
basically did her back to the future too
and she went back in time in order to
tell her old self to buy bitcoin and
secure a board ape so she becomes mega
rich but just kidding but not really now
because of her future knowledge she
wrapped red tape around time travel and
made it so that the entire property
belonged to only hair the way that time
travel works in the film is that there's
one set timeline and if you go back and
change things then it affects all future
events and basically wipes things clean
from the moment that they were changed
if someone were to travel back in time
dance on the titanic and steer it out of
the way of the iceberg then when they
returned home their memories of that
being the true history would start to
solidify as if that's the way that it's
always happened this is why adam can
meet his younger self and not remember
it happening to him if he were to return
to 2050 the events i played out would
then become his memories and so on and
so forth hope that makes sense and if it
doesn't yet i'm lost at this point now
you can affect the past which in turn
affects the future and there's several
fixed points in time rather than the mcu
multiverse time split theory this gets
lip service paid to in the film and
hilariously young adam has a childlike
wonder of the equipment and weapons
questioning if one's a lightsaber with
it also being sort of like a tv a time
stick now a big twist comes in the film
when we learn that the timeline we see
is actually one that's already had
somewhat of a deal over and that the
young adam exists in one where saurian
has already gone back and changed a lot
of things we'll talk about this later on
but it's very important to bear in mind
now while saddam initially wants to go
back to 2018 he initially lands four
years later in 2022 he introduces
himself to his younger version who's
played by walker scobel walker is
brilliant in the film and for such a
young guy he does a great job of
recapturing the frantic almost adlib
dialogue that reynolds is famous for you
really can't believe that they're the
same character at different points in
their lives and it helps elevate the
film a lot as they start to work
together now adam's young self is just
as mouthy as he is but he's small and
weak and thus is easily susceptible to
police we find him being tormented by
them leading to him being collected by
his mother and we learn that his father
passed away a year ago which has had a
detrimental effect on him now we get a
pretty cool scene where young adam
realizes just who this man is and elder
adam explains that he's there on a
rescue mission however just as young
adam helps the older one the older one
also helps the young one and it's sort
of like poetry it rhymes in a way now
after the death of his dad adam was very
much like a person who watches the
videos but they don't subscribe they're
there but they're not really there and
because of this he was a complete jerk
to his mother adult adam regrets this
massively as he realizes how nice she
was to him and it's something that he
still loses sleep over it's a poignant
moment and reynolds decides to be the
father figure to his past self that he
lost that one eventually he comes to
realize he might be trying to rush adam
through years of growth and he also
visits his mother at a bar i was really
insisting that they wouldn't do a back
to the future where she'd try and get it
on with him but luckily they dodged that
bullet even if saurian doesn't we're
getting ahead of ourselves but what adam
project is excellently is that it has
these sentimental moments that make it
more than just a time travel story
there's also cool thematic pieces and
even a fight to the song good times bad
times by led zeppelin it's an app choice
and as robert plant talks about losing
his love adam is saved by his wife laura
who sadly doesn't get enough screen time
the song also discusses the idea of what
it's like to be a man and doing the
right thing both of which are things
adam struggles with across time in the
movie along the way adam confronts a
bully who gets some cool hoverboard
riding soldiers and some great action
scenes and also one that's a bit like
the speeder bike chase in return of the
jedi lightsabers and all we also get an
explanation as to what happened to laura
as she's clearly not dead like adam was
told we learned she found something
strange in the jump blocks of a time jet
that returned from 2018. this was never
have supposed to happen and though they
could have just went back to watch
infinity war up at night something fishy
was definitely going on now the real
reason it went there was because saurian
gave tips to her younger self which
changed the time stream meaning it
wasn't the same time that she went to
the past self not only invested heavily
but she managed to gain control of the
time program and she used this for
personal gain even if her head seemed
like it was cgi'd badly onto her body
for the entire movie now sorian going
back in time and changing everything
robbed the entire world of the lives
they were meant to lead and this
included adam it's here that he's urged
to go back to 2018 and end time travel
but in doing this it would mean that
laura and adam never met as they only
cross paths on the programme thus adam
thinks that they needed saurian's
intervention in order to fall in love
and it puts him in a bit of a moral
quandary however laura is adamant that
they're meant to be together and that
their marriage is a sort of fixed point
in time which does get confirmed at the
end of the movie now this moment cuts
even deeper as they're attacked which
leaves laura having to make a final
stand from this point on the two atoms
go back to 2018 this year where they
meet their father played by mark ruffalo
eerily he says most of you will die
before you finish your life's work which
is the exact same thing that happened to
him interestingly they get into a debate
over the origin of the phrase it's
lighter than you think as technically it
is like and then lewis thinks as both
adams are from the future and his story
is lighter than he thinks so lots of
timey tiny whiny wibbly wobbly stuff to
get your head around now lewis despite
being told that the past and future have
already been ruined by saurian refuses
to help put the genie back in the bottle
as he's worried it might further
destabilize the time space continuum
fortunately the theme of young adam
needing a father figure arises again as
old adams says that his younger self
needs him so their mission becomes to
defeat biff tanento saurian now
realizing that he spent too much time on
time travel he decides to go with the
second chance he's been given and thus
the three set out to destroy it once and
for all this all leads to a
confrontation in a super cool fight as
saurian threatens young adam in the
hopes of getting the drive that can
unlock everything while matthew in the
future here it saves the day due to the
metal in the armor-piercing bullets
being magnetic lou is counted on this
and as saurian fires a bullet at him it
gets pulled into the magnetic field of
the generator and thus goes through
saurian's past self in order to continue
its path it's a moment akin to the
ending of looper and because of the
future having to rely on the past
saurian's younger cgidh self dying means
her older version has to die too now
sticking to the rules of how the
space-time continuum should be lewis
refuses to hear how he died sadly it
seems like this is a fixed point in time
and that he was always meant to pass
away no matter what this is confirmed
because we catch a young adam and his
mother at the end of the movie and she's
going through the insurance papers she
says she wants to do what how lewis did
and the whole hug between adam and his
mother doesn't work unless he goes it's
really heartbreaking and watching lewis
accept his fate whilst delivering a
speech about how much he loves his son
really means a lot he trusts in the
strength of adam and knows that no
matter what they are going to make it 30
years takes a long time to correct and
thus they have some time together before
they return to their own times in the
back garden they all play baseball one
last time and ah
i'm not crying you are you are you
stupid punk you're always crying
no young adam promises to give his
mother a hug so hard it could break her
ribs and it's such an emotional ending
about loss acceptance and remembering
the good times amongst the bad watching
them disappear is a great way to say
goodbye and back in the present he
watches young adam tells his mother he
loves her after pretending to mock her
old adam also meets laura and when they
were playing catch he did wonder if
they'd be able to remember the adventure
that they'd gone on as we learned
earlier memories altered to fit the past
however this rule gets broken for the
final few scenes old adam definitely
remembers laura as he said that he found
her and the memories being kept is
further cemented by young adam him
hugging his mother shows he remembers
the final conversation with his older
self and he wouldn't be able to do this
if he'd forgotten everything all in all
it's a really good ending and as for my
thoughts on the movie i had a lot of fun
with it i don't think it's really
inventing the wheel or time travel and
doing anything we haven't seen before
but it still had a lot of dramatic and
great action moments though reynolds is
great and often times he has to carry
movies i think the whole cast here are
really good and zoe saldona mark ruffalo
and walker scobel handle the material
really really well i'm excited to see
what reynolds and levy do next as
they've had two great original ip films
back to back and it's nice to see them
hitting home runs like this on new
properties overall the adam project was
great and it gets an 8 out of 10. i'd
obviously love to hear your thoughts so
make sure you comment below and let me
know if you enjoyed the video then
please hit the thumbs up button and on
screen right now we have a breakdown of
the batman which you should definitely
go check out if not then thanks for
sitting through the video i hope you
enjoy your weekend i'll see you on the
next one you take care peace